what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
doing my best to make sense of the
latest shocking events in the seven
deadly sins story including a very
bloody betrayal that I was not expecting
the air of chaos is definitely here and
it is an era of shocking twists and
turns
I thought Merlin was the master of
secret plans and unexpected twists but
the latest chapter of the seven deadly
sins brought about a twist that even
Merlin failed to anticipate things are
changing quickly and the story's moving
in ways that I personally had not
expected so let's break it all down and
try to make sense of it right now if you
enjoy the seven deadly sins content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know it definitely helps
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications I always say this but if
you don't go through the trouble of
clicking off the option that says all
notifications you're gonna miss a lot of
our videos
it's just how YouTube works you can hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
out Pro for all the latest news and
updates on the seven deadly sins and
finally this video will of course
feature seven deadly sins manga spoilers
we're talking about the very latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned as chapter three three eight
begins Mele Otis asks outright whether
Merlyn manipulated the seven deadly sins
in order to revive chaos some legendary
monstrous being that may not even be
real in the first place this was the big
question that we were all wondering
during these past few chapters did
Merlyn really betrayed the seven deadly
sins in order to achieve a secret goal
that they didn't even know about however
as soon as meliodas brings up the
possibility that the mythical creature
known as chaos may not be real the Lady
of the lake speaks up she says that
chaos definitely does exist and that
they've all been face-to-face with it
for a long time the sins Hawk and
Elizabeth are confused and they don't
seem to get the hint
so the Lady of the lake clarifies by
saying they've been traveling on its
back
this entire time and what's more she has
been patiently waiting it for her
resurrection add these words everyone's
attention turns to hawks mama hawk is
doubtful at first he doesn't think that
his mama could possibly be this
legendary chaos creature but then we see
the massive pig's body deflate like a
popped balloon the Lady of the lake says
that chaos is a will so it doesn't
manifest in physical form meaning that
that which the demon king of the supreme
deity thought that they had sealed away
was not truly chaos not sure what
exactly this means but after Hawkes
Mama's body deflates King notices that
the deflated material that's left isn't
the actual skin of a pig rather what's
left is just a shell that was made up of
multiple layers of moss when Arthur asks
what happened to the actual contents of
Hawkes mama
Merlin responds that the contents are
now within Arthur they have been within
him ever since he was resurrected as the
king of chaos the reason why Arthur was
able to use that strange reality
altering magic earlier was because
Arthur now has the power of chaos within
him meliodas tells Merlin to just turn
Arthur back to normal but she explains
that this is impossible
chaos has chosen to live inside Arthur
which means that Arthur is the destined
king of chaos now the oldest is pretty
upset that Merlin has done all of this
without telling the sins anything about
it and without even taking what Arthur
wants into consideration but Arthur
interrupts them and tells them that
there is no need to argue because of him
Arthur explains that the seven deadly
sins are the heroes he looks up to and
he doesn't want them to fight because of
someone like him he admires the seven
deadly sins and he truly appreciates
everything that Merlin has done for him
since they first met Merlin had of
course trained Arthur and took him under
her wing and she had even told him to
become a king who makes the impossible
possible this is cool because the power
of chaos really does seem to make the
impossible possible but it is also cool
because it appears to be channeling my
favorite anime character of all time
coming off from Gurren Lagann
then as Arthur is speaking the physical
world around them begins to change again
Arthur's strange new chaos ability seems
to be activating without him even
realizing it and the nature of the power
seems to reflect his emotions it seems
to me that when he is feeling a
particularly strong emotion the power of
chaos activates and changes the physical
world around them in a way that reflects
Arthur's emotions and this seems to go
for both positive and negative emotions
this is without a doubt a very
interesting and potentially dangerous
ability nothing like we've ever seen
before in the seven deadly sins
although it is potentially very Opie if
Arthur can learn how to control it then
just as Arthur finishes talking about
becoming a great King who can protect
everyone and create the kind of world
that no one has seen before his strange
pet calf emerges from an opening in the
boar hat bar Kath says that he or she or
it whatever calf is is glad that Arthur
is alive and it leaps towards him
however the Lady of the lake suddenly
recognizes that calf is something or
someone who doesn't mean well - Arthur
and the lady screams at Merlin not to
let calf get close to Arthur
but before Merlin can react Kath
suddenly opens its massive mouth which
features three rows of razor-sharp teeth
and attempts to eat Arthur
luckily meliodas is able to react and
shove Arthur out of the way but not
before calf manages to bite off Arthur's
right arm man Arthur is really not a
lucky guy when it comes to being injured
slash killed in battle needless to say
everyone is shocked by what just
happened and Arthur is of course
experiencing intense pain but the sins
don't have much time to find their
bearings because the Lady of the lake
urges them to recover Arthur's arm
immediately otherwise they will soon
realize how powerful even a fragment of
chaos can be as calf devours Arthur's
arm it begins to sprout monstrous legs
and it is seemingly undergoing a major
transformation the final page of the
chapter warns us that a power which can
altered the world itself is now in the
wrong hands and a crisis is about to
occur Kath this strange an apparently
evil creature has absorbed a fragment of
chaos and there is no telling how
powerful this strange creature from
purgatory will now become this chapter
was definitely something first off
pretty much everything from the
prisoners of the sky movie regarding
Hawks mama being the mother of chaos has
now been confirmed in the movie we even
saw that a portion of the mass on Hawks
momma's behind had peeled off to reveal
a shining white light beneath and this
chapter went on to confirm that the
green coating around Hawks mama was
nothing but a shell made up of various
layers of moss second one of the
weirdest twists in the entire story has
just come to pass Kath that mysterious
creature from purgatory who I thought
loved Arthur and was trying to protect
him suddenly turned on him and tried to
devour him in order to gain the power of
chaos I mean I think that in the past
Kath was actually shown playfully
chewing on Arthur's hair but who would
have thought that this was actually
foreshadowing for Kath's true monstrous
intentions we know that calf is as I
said originally a creature from
purgatory and it was named after cath
Pollock a monster from Arthurian legend
we also know that as soon as Kath showed
up the Lady of the lake recognized that
Kath was a threat to Arthur even before
it attacked him meanwhile for some
reason Merlin and the sins could not
sense that Kath had any evil intentions
before Arthur was actually attacked this
is interesting but I wonder why the Lady
of the lake had this intuition while the
sins did not knowing what we don't know
it is safe to assume that just like
Merlin had believed that Arthur was
destined to become the king of chaos
this mysterious creature from purgatory
known as Kath had the same intuition in
my opinion it is likely that calf
clunked - Arthur specifically because it
knew that Arthur would one day become
the king of chaos and he wanted to make
sure that it would have the opportunity
to devour him and steal his power Kath
has been planning this since the very
beginning and what's more
kath is more than just some random
creature the fact that the Lady of the
lake seemed to recognize Kath as
something more than just a random
creature from purgatory confirms that
Kath is probably a far bigger threat
than it might have seemed at first
glance since the one big unanswered
question in the story is of course the
fate of the supreme deity I wonder
whether Kath is somehow related to the
supreme deity was the supreme deity
somehow sealed inside this creature
known as Kath and was she just biding
her time until the demon king was
defeated and chaos was resurrected in
order to make her move is her plan to
break out of the seal using the power of
chaos and claimed supremacy over all of
the clans or is Kath just another
completely independent villain whose
true intentions are only going to make
sense later on once we learn more about
it and its true origins because of how
the story has been going so far and
because of maryland's whole backstory
including of course the destruction of
Valhalla win by the supreme deity and
the demon king I am leaning towards the
idea that Kath is related to the supreme
deity in some way perhaps the reason why
we haven't heard anything from the
supreme deity yet is because she's been
sealed away inside Kath I am going to
assume that there is a connection
between Kath and the supreme deity
although to be fair I could be
completely off-base but I will say this
much if we look back to our theory and
legend and the legends of Great Britain
in general Kath Pollock the creature
that Kath was clearly based on is a
monstrous cat whose mother was hanwen a
legendary great white pig
we know that Hawks mama is a giant pig
and in the prisoners of the sky movie we
saw that she was white on the inside we
also know that Hawks mama was chaos and
that chaos created the demon king in the
supreme deity in the first place so if
we take the story about calf from
Arthurian legend then just like Kath
Paula was born of hand when the pig
perhaps the cat from the seven deadly
sins is the supreme deity who was
herself born of chaos the same chaos
that for most of the
story took the form of a giant pig it is
important to note that in some Arthurian
stories Arthur himself fights Kath
Pollock and in some versions of the
story Kath
kills Arthur while in others Arthur
defeats calf naka Basu Sookie definitely
takes a lot of inspiration from
Arthurian legend and many of his
characters including cath and Hawkes
mama are inspired by specific characters
from Arthurian legend in this case
caf-pow Luke and hen when the pig but
with that said knock-up also takes a lot
of liberties with these legends and the
story of the seven deadly sins is only
very loosely based on our xxx and legend
so it is also possible that Kathleen
different creature that isn't
necessarily related to the supreme deity
however if that is the case then we're
still going to need to get Cath's
backstory and why exactly this creature
was hanging around Arthur this entire
time and also why is it so determined to
absorb the power of chaos please let me
know what you guys think how did you
like this insane chapter and why do you
think that calf attacked arthur is cat
the supreme deity in disguise is it just
an independent villainous creature or is
there something else going on here
something that I am missing also how was
the Lady of the lake able to tell right
away that calf had evil intentions when
none of the sins were able to pick up on
it let me know down below if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more 7
that Leigh sense content on the channel
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar I
want to give a massive thank you to all
of our anime uproar patrons who support
the channel and make what we do possible
with all the problems on YouTube lately
patron support means more than ever so
thank you guys so much special thanks to
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
eldritch fitty dolla beat Anatole
kazansky alpha do on hell crews and team
Sparky 65 and I can't forget the ones
who rise above all other clans
a huge thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including Ingrid ah
Ilona Adam Matty Mac makoto-kun the
world stealers the school bus and Tyson
Queenie No
if you enjoy our content and you feel we
provide value for you please consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]